[Musik]
sie geht ins kino
sie ist in kiel
u
ich gehe in den keller
ich bin im keller
[Musik]
sie setzt sich auf den stuhl
sie sitzt auf dem stuhl
die katze klettert auf den
die katze ist auf dem baum
der hund rennt an den zaun
der hund bellt am zaun
sie hängt die hose an den
kleiderständern
die hose hängt am kleiderständer
ich gehe in die bäckerei
ich bin in der bäckerei
ich lege mich aufs sofa
[Musik]
ich liege auf dem sofa
ich gehe in die schule
ich bin in der schule
er stellt das sofa vor das fenster
das sofa steht vor dem fenster
ich gehe in die apotheke
ich bin in der apotheke
ich gehe in die küche
ich bin in der küche
ich gehe in die disco
ich bin in der disco
sie bauen ein hochhaus zwischen die
kirche und den supermarkt
das hochhaus steht zwischen der kirche
und dem supermarkt
ich gehe in den supermarkt
ich bin im supermarkt
ich gehe in den kleiderladen
ich bin im kleiderladen
ich gehe in den zoo
ich bin im zoo
o
ich gehe in den
garten
ich bin im garten
ich gehe ins muss
um
[Musik]
ich bin im museum
ich gehe ins schwimmbad
ich bin im schwimmbad
ich gehe ins krankenhaus
ich bin im krankenhaus
ich gehe ins erdgeschoss
ich bin im erdgeschoss
ich gehe ins schlafzimmer
ich bin im schlafzimmer
ich gehe in die berge
ich bin in den
gehen
er hängt die lampe über den
die lampe hängt über dem tisch
ich gehe in die ferien
[Musik]
ich bin in den ferien
ich gehe an die frische luft
ich bin an der frischen luft
ich gehe an die haltestelle
ich bin an der haltestelle
ich gehe an die tür
ich bin an der tür
ich gehe ans konzert
ich bin am konzert
ich gehe ans fenster
ich bin am fenster
ich fahre
ans meer
ich bin am meer
schwimmer ans ufer
ich bin am ufer
gehe auf den friedhof
ich bin auf dem friedhof
ich gehe auf
an
ich bin auf dem turm
ich gehe auf den balkon
ich bin auf dem bei
ich fahre auf den parkplatz
ich bin auf dem parkplatz
ich gehe
auf die wiese
ich bin auf der wiese
ich gehe auf die toilette
ich bin auf der toilette
ich gehe auf die post
ich bin auf
ist
ich gehe aufs gymnasium
ich bin auf dem gymnasium
jung
er geht vor das haus
er ist vor dem haus
er geht hinter das haus
er ist hinter dem haus
ich setze mich auf den stuhl
ich sitze auf dem stuhl
ich setze mich auf die bank
ich sitze auf der bank
sie lebt den teppich unter den tisch
der teppich liegt unter dem tisch
sie liegt den teppich vor die tür
der teppich liegt vor der tür
sie legt den teppich neben die dusche
der teppich liegt neben der dusche
sie legt das buch auf den tisch
das buch liegt auf dem tisch
sie liegt das kissen aufs bett
das kissen liegt auf dem bett
sie lebt das kissen auf den sessel
das kissen liegt auf dem sessel
sie legt das handy unter das bett
das handy liegt unter dem bett
sie liegt die brille auf das buch
die brille liegt auf dem buch
er hängt die jacke an den
kleiderständern
die jacke hängt am kleiderständer
er hängt die uhr neben das fenster
die uhr hängt neben dem fenster
er stellt die tasse neben den laptop
die tasse steht neben dem laptop
er stellt die schuhe vor die tür
die schuhe stehen vor der tür
er stellt das fahrrad neben die garage
das fahrrad steht neben der garage
er stellt die boxen auf den boden
die boxen stehen auf dem boden
er stellt die lampe zwischen das regal
unters sofa
die lampe steht zwischen dem regal
und dem sofa
er wirft den abfall in den eimer
der abfall liegt im eimer sie hängt das
kleid in den schrank
das kleid hängt im schrank
er geht in den
mag
er ist im park
sie legt das gemüse in den kühlschrank
das gemüse ist im kühlschrank
er schiesst den ball ins tor
das flugzeug fliegt über das meer
dunkle wolken ziehen am himmel auf
im herbst fallen die blätter auf den
boden
erwischt den dreck unter den teppich
der bus hält an der haltestelle
der fluss fließt durch das tal an der
nächsten kreuzung musst du rechts
abbiegen
die bäckerei steht neben der kirche
hinter der schule gibt es ein
fußballfeld
die leute sollen sich am strand
andreas surft auf der welle
er fällt ins wasser
manuel springt ins meer
der postbote wirft den brief in den
briefkasten
der schneefall
auf die dächer
der hund steht auf dem rücken von dem
esel
die katze steht auf dem hund
der hahn steht auf der katze in welcher
stadt sind die tiere
schreibt die antwort in die kommentare
[Musik]
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video